some people say that our political
situation could not get
any worse but i am an optimist i think
that our political situation
could get much much worse and
representative
michael mccall is here to explain how
it's not only a threat to these these
children who are being exploited
but again they know the laws in our
country but it's also a threat to
americans
of this population coming in and yeah
biden has cut off these agreements with
mexico
central america where they'd have to
stay in mexico to apply for asylum
and now they're i've seen this before
martha i i predict this
and by summer you're going to see as my
governor just said
probably you know somewhere around a
million people trying to get into this
country
illegally and as i said before it's
ironic
that you can get into this country
illegally easier than you get a tour of
this capital
right behind me now on the bright side
we already have
about a million illegal aliens coming in
every year
so that's not what's different i think
what's different here is he's saying
it's going to be a million
sort of all at once like the chains are
all broken
no restraint left country being flooded
with foreign nationals
so much to look forward to i'm michael
knowles the michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show amid our
immigration crisis my favorite comment
yesterday is a more serious question
actually from carol
who asks if these miners
are unaccompanied how can they be
separated from their parents
that's actually a good question uh
pointing out that unaccompanied means
you know you're alone you don't have an
escort with you
uh the the answer to this is that so
many people are entering our country
right now that you have unaccompanied
minors you have
uh minors who are separated from either
their relatives or who know the coyotes
who brought them over
or people who are posing to be their
relatives
it's just an absolute mess and you're
probably only hearing about it on shows
like this one because the mainstream
media simply do not want to cover
this sort of thing but it doesn't bode
very well for the health and wellness of
our country
and if you are concerned about your
health and wellness you got to check out
hymns
for hymns.com is all about men's
wellness
need help with ed hair loss or have a
cold hems is here for you
kim's makes it easy hims connects you
with a licensed medical professional
online
who can prescribe fda approved
prescription medication to treat ed
you get the same active ingredient as
that expensive little pill but without
the expensive price tag
no embarrassing conversations no
expensive appointments just answer a few
questions online about your medical
history
and a provider will confidentially
review if approved
your medication is shipped directly to
your door in discrete packaging shipping
is free
no more searching online for answers to
questions about ed or sexual wellness
just go to your hems account ask a
medical professional you can trust
why live with ed when the solution can
be so simple i know a lot of guys don't
want to talk about that sort of a
problem
but it afflicts a lot of men and there
are some simple solutions here
try hymns today by starting out with a
free online visit go to for hymns.com
michael for your free visit that's for
hims.com
michael f-o-r-h-i-m-s com michael
prescription products are subject to
medical provider approval and require an
online consultation with a medical
provider who will determine if a
prescription is appropriate
see website for full details and safety
information remember that is for
hims.com
michael we have this major issue
at the border it's not only because joe
biden is president
these border surges happen under just
about every single administration
what is different is how the
administrations deal with it
so donald trump took a much more serious
stance on this than his predecessors
where he formed agreements whereby
illegal aliens coming from south america
and below mexico would have to apply for
asylum say in mexico they would not be
able to
just go walk on right through and then
pretend to be seeking refuge in the
united states when really they're just
economic migrants
donald trump instituted many other
policies that discouraged this kind of
cro illegal crossing of the border what
biden is doing is the opposite he's
taking away
the trump safeguards and he's creating
new incentives for people to come
illegally what happens when you
incentivize
a certain behavior you get more of that
behavior
which is why gen saki our favorite
current white house press secretary
refuses to give the numbers on the
people crossing illegally
why won't you confirm that number that's
a very important number
i i i we've been very clear that there
is an increase
that there are more children coming
across the border than we have
facilities for at this point in time
those numbers are tracked by the
department of homeland security so i'm
certainly i'm just suggesting that you
talk to them about specifics them jen
they won't confirm the numbers
well i would encourage you to go back to
them and ask them again we're not going
to confirm them from the white house
it's not our program it's the department
of homeland security department is the
white house encouraging the department
to release those numbers
and in the spirit of transparency that
the secretary promised here at this
point we certainly encourage
transparency but what i also think is
important is to talk about what the root
causes are here and what we're doing
from a policy standpoint to try to
address
the challenges uh that we're facing and
that these kids are facing as they come
across the border
okay can you just give us the numbers no
we can't
this you've got to talk to homeland
security yeah we talked to homeland
security they said we got to talk to you
no yeah no i know though but we can't
because look it's not our program i mean
i know that we are
the leaders of the executive branch i
know that we are running this entire
branch of the government but no you got
to talk to the little bureaucratic
agency because they because we report to
them because what do we have to do what
come on
we're just figureheads over here we're
not we're not actually running the show
okay well can you just look i we know
you have the numbers
we know dhs has the number do you want
dhs to release the numbers well no i'm
not i'm not i'm not saying necessarily
they should don't please don't interpret
this to believe
that we want you at dhs to release the
numbers why can't you just tell us the
numbers well because
we want to focus on solutions well okay
the first part of finding a solution is
diagnosing the problem
give us the numbers they won't do it
they won't
admit these record numbers they won't
even admit
that what is going on at the border
constitutes a crisis
they want no labels is this a crisis at
the word
look i don't think we need to sit here
and put new labels on what we have
already conveyed is challenging what we
have conveyed as a top
priority for the president what our
policy teams are working on
every single day obviously there was a
trip to the border uh
this weekend they are working over the
course of
every day since then on putting in place
policies that can help address
what we're seeing and and help ensure
that we are keeping these kids safe
and moving them as quickly as possible
from border patrol facilities to
uh to shelters okay so
she's got her story and she's sticking
to it she's not gonna give you
the numbers because she's focused on
policy solutions as though you can't do
both at the same time
say okay here's the problem and here's
the solution she won't
call it a crisis doesn't want to admit
that it's a crisis
because she's so focused on policy
solutions she doesn't ever think
about what she might call the problem
itself
so let's talk about the policy solutions
that's what that's what jensaki wants to
talk about what are those
policy solutions why kids in cages of
course
cbs news tonight has learned there are
more than 3 200 unaccompanied migrant
children in customs and border
protection custody
a total that has nearly tripled in the
last two weeks
for now these children are being held in
facilities that are managed by customs
and border protection but they are meant
for
adults we know that several federal
agencies right now are working together
on this issue and late this afternoon
cbs news got a statement from the office
of refugee and resettlement that says in
part
they are looking at several options for
long-term and short-term
solutions that will help safely take
care of these children
this news report is an absolute
masterpiece of propaganda
it's become sort of tedious even to say
imagine what the news report would be
under the trump administration but just
just actually pay attention to what it
was here
obviously under the trump administration
if you know
and any border agent sneezed the wrong
way this was
genocide and trump is literally hitler
putting people into camps or something
but in the biden administration where
they are
actually putting more kids into more
cages than donald trump
ever did cages by the way that the obama
biden administration billed
in that world we have
record number of people she acknowledges
then
we have minors being put in border
facilities
managed by customs and border protection
not they're not cages
they're they're facilities border
facilities managed by cbp
and then if that's the first little part
of the report immediately she goes
and they're working really hard and
they're really trying to get the kids
out and i
we talked to one of the officials and he
promised they're going to do a really
good job
and so that's what they all say they're
going to do and you know goodness
gracious we believe them
so that's the good that's the news not
what not what's happening that's a
little minor part of the news but all
those promises
that we're getting because they're
really good guys in the biden
administration they're
they're yeah they're putting kids in
cages but they you know they don't wanna
you know they i mean they're doing it
but they don't they'd rather not
you know and they're really the first
thing they can they're gonna
stop doing that so good on them right
imagine imagine that never admitting
nothing an old sort of
italian american new york bit of
street wisdom is to deny
until you die do not admit anything
just just keep a straight face
and say absolutely no problems here
don't answer questions
joe biden was just at some small
business in washington dc
and he was doing a little bit of a photo
stop joe biden has now gone 49 days i
guess it is
without a press conference by far the
longest in modern history for president
to go without a
a direct press conference biden is asked
very simple question
what's your comment about the crisis on
the border his
press aides all but defenestrate the
reporters who dare ask that question
come on let's go thank you guys thank
you so much come on let's go get out of
here get out of here you reporters you
don't get to do that you get you ask
those questions of trump
you don't ask those questions of my guy
joe is just there kind of
looking dazed kind of wandering around
by the cash register huh where
what why am i in there in a general
store in washington dc
oh look at that is that a yo-yo he has
no idea what's going on he doesn't know
what's going on
at the moment he doesn't know what's
going on at the border either and that's
why he won't
give an answer and by the way he is
smart not to answer and certainly the
aides who are advising him are smart not
to let him answer
there's no good answer he can give so he
just wants to
move past it you know
this is uh this is a problem especially
for like christians in politics because
i think the impulse is apologize admit
what you were
when you were wrong have humility and
that's all very important that's what we
all try to do in our personal lives and
and we try to do it as much as is
possible in our political lives
but we're living in this graceless
culture right now
where the minute that you give in to the
mob
just even like a tiny little bit you're
done you're toast there's no
there's no apology that will ever
suffice for them
so i think it's very important to
recognize
what the political context is and what
you can do here
there are a couple governors who have uh
in the democratic party who have
apologized when there have been
accusations against them and they're
much the worse for it and joe biden we
can make fun of him and he's dazed and
confused all day long
but that guy is still the president
somehow somehow that guy is still the
president pretty
amazing when you know when you don't
have the wherewithal necessarily all
your all your pistons firing
speaking of pistons firing you gotta go
check out rock auto rockauto.com is so
much easier than walking into a store
and someone demanding quick answers to
questions like
hey michael why are you so handsome no
that's not what they ask what they
usually ask is hey is your
is your honda you know a gt7 or a z25 i
don't know what my honda is it's
it's like uh it's a sedan right uh then
they go into the back
they order the part online they charge
you twice as much don't do that that's
absolutely
crazy go to rockauto.com at your desk
in your pocket rockauto.com always
offers the lowest prices possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear
like airlines do you know it's not going
to be this kind of gimmicky thing oh you
got to order it on tuesday to save
x percent no reliably low prices the
same prices for pros and
do-it-yourselfers
the website is so easy to navigate and
this is the most shocking part
even i can do it they're a family
business serving auto parts customers
online for 20 years
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car
or truck then write knowles canada
w-l-e-s and their how did you hear about
us box
so that they know we sent you gavin
newsom
we call him nussolini back in my former
state of california
gavin newsom unlike joe biden is a
politician who has occasionally
answered his critics answered some of
the accusations against him
and what's he going to get for it well
he's about to be recalled
here is newsome addressing his stake you
know
i know our progress hasn't always felt
fast enough
and look we've made mistakes i have made
mistakes
but we own them we learn from them and
we never
stop trying after all that's that's the
california spirit
we're bent but not broken bloodied but
unbowed resolved to make brighter days
ahead
and not to let the pain of last year to
deter us from the hopefulness
of tomorrow look the state of our state
it remains determined i
remain determined and i just want you to
know we're not going to change
course just because of a few naysayers
and and doomsdayers
look we're not going to change course
just because our we're on the wrong
course
okay now we're not going to decide to
change our strategy just because our
strategy isn't working all right
i am the absolute glibist politician in
america gavin newsom and i
i simply don't possess the uh
intellectual or
political faculties to change anything
not at all all right
you know we make mistakes but we own our
mistakes except i'm not owning my
mistakes
because i'm not changing course at all
what
what is that kind of a glib attitude
going to get gavin newsom it's going to
get him recalled
unless the democrats can pull some
miracle and invalidate
half a million signatures on these
petitions which maybe they can
it would be pretty rich because now
we're told that
anytime you invalidate any ineligible
voter
you know from the voter rolls that
that's voter suppression and you're a
racist and it's un-american
but sure they're going to try to do it
it just it doesn't seem like it's going
to work out particularly well for them
now will anyone beat gavin newsom in
this prospective runoff
i don't know i don't know if they they
can but it certainly would appear to be
what he's aiming at
a lesson a lesson from these politicians
the clever ones and the less clever ones
do not apologize to the mob it's very
good to apologize
in good faith to people who are going to
accept your apology and good faith in
your in your life
but when the mob is coming after you you
really can't apologize i
i saw this yesterday with this poor
schlub this this fellow winston marshall
who is a musician in mumford and sons
i actually really like mumford and sons
i know maybe i'm just a
a child of the i was a teenager in the
20 teens so i
i really liked mumford and sons but this
guy i think he's a good musician
and he espoused a very interesting point
of view the other day on twitter he said
congratulations andy no finally had
the time to read your important book
you're a brave man you know andy no
a friend of the show friend of mine he
wrote this book about antifa he has been
targeted more than just about anybody by
antifa
he suffered a brain bleed because of
these antifa militants and he's got an
excellent book out there
detailing it because the narrative that
we're being told about antifa
is very different from the reality we're
told that antifa is just an idea well
ideas don't give you brain bleeds
so this mumford and sons musician reads
the book
says okay you know i enjoyed the book
and then the backlash came they were
very
very upset that he would read a memoir
by a guy who got a brain bleed by
leftist
terrorists and they're even more upset
that he would endorse the book
so he issues an apology mr mumford and
sons writes
over the past few days i have come to
better understand the pain caused by the
book that i endorsed
i have offended not only a lot of people
i don't know but also those closest to
me
including my bandmates and for that i'm
truly sorry
as a result of my actions i'm taking
time away from the band to examine my
blind spots
for now please know that i realize how
my endorsements have the potential to be
viewed as approvals of hateful divisive
behavior i apologize as this was not at
all my intention
oh buddy buddy buddy buddy
i know exactly what happened here
and you are getting very very
very bad advice here's what happened
this guy
winston marshall i'm just i i know that
i'm just pulling this off the top of my
head but i'm
i would be willing to bet a lot of money
that something like this is what
happened he comes out and he sends a
tweet and he says i enjoyed this book
wow this is a very interesting book you
should consider reading it
then maybe a band mate or two
maybe someone and maybe some marketing
gal
in the publisher's office or some maybe
some people
around him get upset about it
then the twitter trend happens and when
you trend on twitter you feel like the
world is collapsing and around you
then he's getting the deluge of hate the
deluge of mean tweets and emails
and people who are in politics are
accustomed to this
we get that sort of thing basically
every single day so you just don't take
it
all that seriously you know how to deal
with it if you're a pure entertainer
you're really
not used to that kind of thing and so
it's very jarring when it happens
now because we're living in the cancel
culture where the left
attacks people and ruins their careers
for saying perfectly ordinary things
this guy winston is in total survival
mode he's oh my gosh i'm starting to
lose things this is bad this has never
happened i've just gotta
stop the bleeding i've just gotta stop
whatever's happening
and some unscrupulous people are going
to go
in and they're going to say hey you've
got to issue a perfectly
unqualified apology and you've got to
step away for a while but then it'll all
be better then you'll get
your career back then you'll get your
reputation back then you'll get
invited to all the same parties then you
get all your money back
and this poor guy believed them
but it's not true it's not true
look in my own career in politics and
media i've
had some moments like this where there's
a lot of pressure to cave into a mob
i know basically everybody who is in
politics and media has had these moments
do not do it it is you only lose by
doing it
you you can't unless you feel you've
really done something wrong and
egregious and then you've got to deal
with that on your own but
if you're just talking about something
like this you can never ever win
by giving in to the mob and the people
advising you to do so are lying to you
they're not that you you think that you
can preserve something that is already
lost
you think that you can get them to like
you again you won't you won't i
i would encourage this fella mr marshall
if he listens to this show
if he reads andy noah's book there's a
fair chance he listens to this show
uh don't do it reverse course stick to
your guns go out there and defend andy
now
at least you'll keep your dignity you'll
keep more of your career i think
if you end up doing that if you show
that you've got a spine but even if you
even if you're gonna you're gonna lose
your career either way
at a at a certain level of this kind of
a moment right
that seems like the likely thing and so
at least keep your dignity that's what i
would do
speaking of changes of heart milo
yiannopoulos
milo yiannopoulos very famous right-wing
provocateur sort of famously gay
uh milo is now ex-gay
according to milo milo is saying he's
ex-gay he's
i think he's gay married but he's like
they're just not not doing that anymore
they're living together as roommates
and people are making fun of milo for
this is this a troll
i don't maybe it is i don't know milo is
sort of a famous performance artist so
maybe he's just kind of
he's just doing it as a publicity stunt
or something but i'm going to take it
seriously i'm going to say he actually
is going to be xk now what does that
mean he's not
saying that he's no longer sexually
attracted to men
he's not saying that he is now sexually
attracted to women
i mean just read the interview he's
explicitly not saying that he's saying
it's very difficult for him and he still
wants to
sleep with his housemate as he now calls
him
but he's saying i am choosing not to
indulge
in those desires and people are very
angry at milo for this
why would anyone be angry at milo for
this
why wha what is the problem what is it
any of your business just like people
always say what is it your business if
johnny wants to sleep with jack well on
the flip side
why is it any of your business if johnny
doesn't want to sleep with jack
if if we're told that we now can
construct our own sexual identities
why is it the case that the the sexual
identities can only go in one direction
why is it that it can only go in the
direction of indulging one's
natural desires why can't it go in the
other direction too if some guy comes
out and says you know
i've done that a lot i've done it for a
long time
but now as i've been thinking about it
and praying about it i
i don't want to do that anymore i i
my sort of mind does not want to do that
my
sort of more fleshly desires do want to
do that and so i'm going to try to
tame my fleshly desires because that in
my view is
is the right thing to do and so that's
what i want to do now
why would anybody be angry about that
the interview it's really worth taking a
listen
to the the interview you know we will uh
we'll get into that interview in just a
moment because
i just bri first of all it's a very
funny interview
and uh but also he is dealing in pretty
serious ideas so we will
delve into milo's complicated
sexual thought uh in just a moment first
though you got to check out ben's show
uh ben you know ben has something of a
relationship with piers morgan goes back
a number of years now
piers morgan just lost his uh his job
for going after meghan markle ben's can
be talking about that also
you heard us announce it on election
night now the wait is over candace owens
is premiering her new daily wire show
candace you know i've known candace for
years i've known candace since before
she was candace back when she was
red pill black on youtube doing a small
youtube channel
i think drew clavin sort of discovered
her in a way and she was coming on my
show back in those days and we all knew
she was going to be a huge star and she
has a huge star
candice is known as the founder of
blexit
trying to change the narrative
surrounding america's racial minority
communities
she's the author of the new york times
bestseller blackout how black america
can make its second escape from the
democrat plantation
you can join candace every week she
covers a whole host of different topics
from the latest trends to hard-hitting
news get to know the real candace funny
authentic and insightful candace will
premiere on friday march 19th feast of
st
joseph and will be exclusive to our
daily wire members
if you are not already a member head on
over to dailywire.com
subscribe use code candace for 25 off
find out why the left loves to hate
canvas
by going to dailywire.com subscribe use
code candace for 25
off we'll be right back with a lot more
milo yiannopoulos is now ex-gay
he says here is the interview it's in
life site news
he opens up and he says
secular attempts at recovery from sin
are either temporary or completely
ineffective
salvation can only be achieved through
devotion to christ and the works of the
holy catholic and apostolic church
so milo's saying i'm catholic now
and i'm i'm reverting to my catholic
faith and
so i'm going to stop doing all this
other stuff is this just
a troll if it is a troll a it's a funny
troll right i mean it is
you've got this guy who is as
flamboyantly gay as anybody in public
life
and now he's saying nah i'm not doing
that anymore is that a troll
i actually have a reason to think that
it's not a troll
because uh being a catholic myself
milo and i run in some of the same
circles i don't really i don't know him
but i
we do know a number of people in common
and
i i've been hearing about this for a
while that milo is
sort of re-exploring his faith and sort
of taking his faith
catholic faith more seriously so i've
been hearing about this for months maybe
more
maybe even a couple years at this point
so i guess i was not quite as surprised
to see this interview as
some other people were he goes on he
says
i have enjoyed a lifeline a lifelong
affection
for the absurd and the outrageous so
part of me gleefully anticipates the day
i can seize the moral high ground
however briefly
to denounce others for failures of piety
and sobriety
i hope people will support and pray for
me if for no other reason
then they share my delight at the
prospect of milo yiannopoulos
furiously and indignantly railing
against the homosexuals
for sins of the flesh that's a very
funny line
sort of when you see these funny lines
you start to think hold on is this whole
interview just another
another performance but even if it i
mean it's a
funny interview regardless even if it is
you know milo is very famous for trying
on different personalities
one day he's a buttoned up tweed wearing
brit the next day he's wearing you know
sort of big stunner shades and a giant
oversized t-shirt and you know he's kind
of more
hip-hop or something right he tries all
these things on
this does relate to forget the sexual
question for a moment
this does relate to the deeper religious
question
which is that in christianity
and and judaism for that matter god
god is i am right
what is god's name god responds i am
that i am
and christ in the new testament says
before abraham was i am so he's invoking
that he is saying i
i am god right by saying i am the i am i
am the
i am being itself when a culture
finds its identity in i am
then things generally sort of are going
in the right direction
when a culture such as ours casts away
god and religion you are left with a
rather pitiful question which is who am
i
you hear this kind of popular phrase
well i've got to find myself you know
who am i one day i'm this one day on
that especially you see this with
teenagers right they're always trying on
new personalities trying on new
identities
uh because they're sort of adrift they
don't they're not they're not
basing it in this eternal fact of
of being himself then
milo concludes his interview he says
they say if you let one sin in others
will follow and now i truly know what
that means as i've begun to resist
sinful sexual urges i found myself
drinking less smoking less you name it
i confess my weakness for designer shoes
and handbags is
yet to dissipate but i'm coming to
realize however slowly
that lust per augustine is disordered
desire
for all sorts of things not just nfl
players
and so what he is espousing here is a
very
catholic point of view and the way this
story is going to be read is that he's
got some hang up or you know christians
have some hang up
on homosexuality but it's really not the
case at least in the
traditional catholic sexual ethic
it's not just it's not just milo's
sexual desires that are off limits
it's a whole host of them because we
the catholics believe that sex has to be
ordered toward
a purpose right so those sort of things
that you do when you close the blinds
and you're alone at night you know that
that's off limits uh having sex without
the
uh possibility of creating life
without without i'm sorry without the
physical possibility of creating life
that's off limits uh it's a very
it's a very uh focused kind of sexual
morality
chesterton observed he said you know the
one thing that kind of got me curious
about the church
is that it would get attacked for
opposite reasons on the one hand it's
too ascetic right and just on this
particular
rigorous sexual morality but on the
other hand it's too luxurious
the gold of saint peter's and all this
beautiful art and all the fancy clothes
and everything
gets attacked for opposite points of
view i mentioned this whole story
not because i am particularly interested
in milo's sex life
i mention it because of a political
question
that it brings up it reveals the left's
real view of sexual preference and
sexual openness and sexual tolerance
we are told in this society of ours
that we must tolerate people's sexual
behaviors
regardless of our own moral views
whatever they want to do
we should tolerate that okay i i see the
argument for that
so what about milos so what about my
we if you're telling me i'm fine i'm
i'll i'm i'm in we're going to tolerate
people's sexual
behaviors even though even still there
are some things that are off limits but
who knows how long they'll be off limits
we're going to tolerate people's sexual
behaviors whatever they want to do
not not ours to judge well then what
about milos
milo is saying this is this is my
preferred sexual behavior now
i don't i want to be chased and
basically not engaged in sex
because his sexual desires are such that
he doesn't want to indulge them
isn't that good isn't that a good thing
isn't that according to i'm not even
saying according to the catholic logic
i'm saying according to the logic of the
left
isn't that a good thing but it never
cuts that way because the principles
that the left is espousing
are are really not principles so much as
they're creating
a new a new order of society
it's not these universal principles of
tolerance and acceptance
just a new order for society it reminds
me of people attacking mike pence for
not cheating on his wife do you remember
that
they were really upset a few years ago
because it came out that mike pence
would not have dinner dates with women
when his wife wasn't present i kid you
not i had liberal friends of mine
this was before the metoo movement they
were angry with me they said it's awful
that mike pence won't
go on dinner dates with his staff and
with other women
it's not fair it's sexist then five
seconds later the me too movement starts
and mike pence is looking pretty good
right but no because he's kind of damned
if he doesn't damned if he doesn't
there's no there's no fair standard
that's going to apply now speaking of
the metoo movement a sixth woman
has come forward to accuse andrew cuomo
of sexual harassment this woman is
upping the ante here
she's saying not only did he wink at her
from across the room
not only did he buy her a sausage and
pepper sandwich at some political event
no he touched her inappropriately
she does not go on to explain how
she touched her inappropriately we don't
know who the accuser is the identity is
concealed
not quite clear why it's all happening
now right
why why this trickle is so slow
in this sexual scandal for andrew cuomo
but there's another one coming out
against cuomo
my take on this i've told you this from
the beginning is i suspect
that most of these sexual claims are
overblown and opportunistic and
a distraction from the real scandal
the way that you can know this is true
is
describe to me the sexual allegations
against andrew cuomo
take 20 seconds describe to me not who
and when
what are the actual allegations
can you do that i i can't really other
than the video of him handing a sandwich
to a reporter and joking about the
sausage
i they're what i can't name them
it's just so and i don't look i don't
have any particular love for andrew
cuomo he should be out of office
but the way they're doing it is so
dishonest
the reason that guy needs to be out of
office is because he killed
thousands of elderly new yorkers and not
because
of a coordinated political attack on the
guy to say that he's
a creep or something he's kind of a
creep but that's not what this is about
and there's another scandal brewing by
the way it's not just the elderly
andrew cuomo now has another covid
scandal going
because he had an order directing group
homes for people with mental
disabilities
to accept covid patients this order was
issued april 10th
just weeks into the state's lockdown in
an effort to
combat the pandemic and uh
the issue never the order never expired
so people who have problems people who
have mental disabilities specifically
were used as a as a place to send
all the covid patients at their group
homes
i have relatives who work in these group
homes i have a little bit of an inside
track on this little inside knowledge of
what's going on
this is a real scandal
thankfully it didn't spread nearly as
much in these group homes as it did in
the nursing homes
nearly 34 000 34 600 people live in
these kind of group homes
6 900 contracted the disease
i mean thankfully not a ton die over 500
died there's a lot of 552
residents of these these group homes for
people with
intellectual impairments died where's
that scandal no because we're all
talking about the hot dog i want to talk
about the hot dog
i want to talk about milo's hot dog i
don't want to talk about andrew cuomo's
hot dog for that matter
i want to talk about the actual scandal
here that the democrats are doing
everything they possibly can
to distract from but maybe cuomo's
going to lose his job either way
speaking of brash people losing their
jobs
how's that for a segue piers morgan
piers morgan has quit his job on good
morning britain
piers morgan you know he was the the
host after larry king left cnn
then that fellow party went over to good
morning britain
i kind of get a kick out of piers morgan
he's this
sort of tabloid figure in in britain he
can't really pin him down
and sometimes he's really seems really
right-wing sometimes he seems really
left-wing
so piers rightly went after meghan
markle in recent days
and a fellow broadcaster on good morning
britain
started viciously attacking piers morgan
about it pierce just walked offset
and i understand that you don't like
meghan markle you've made it so clear a
number of times on this program a number
of times
and i understand that you've got a
personal relationship
with mega market or had one and she cut
you off
she's entitled to
absolutely diabolical behavior you see
i'm sorry but pierce spouts off on a
regular basis
you can trash me mate but not on my own
show
i i got to give the guy credit for this
i got i
usually 99 times out of a hundred
storming offset looks really bad part of
the reason it looks bad is you have to
take the wires off and you're kind of
fumbling for a while you can hear it on
the mic
appears i guess was wearing a wireless
mic i don't know about the earpiece that
he had in
but he did it so gracefully he's sitting
there kind of taking very you know
british just taking us
taking the licks you know and then the
guy's going you and you
she cut you off yeah and she yeah you're
a jerk you know
and you're trashing her and and he's
just doing this
okay bye see ya just walk so upset
the reason i find this of any interest
to
our political questions here is
because for a long time the right in
this country not the left but the right
has espoused this idea that
we should always just engage in the free
marketplace of ideas we shouldn't know
we should just take
any sort of criticism that's good that's
fine because eventually the good ideas
are going to win out and that's
totally cool we're anti-censorship right
you know we love free speech and so what
pierce did is
sort of opposed to free speech because
he just walked walked off the set
i think he's actually showing us
something valuable here
we are under no obligation because of
our love of free speech
or civil discourse we are under no
obligation to engage
in bad faith conversations and
bad faith debates what was going on
on good morning britain it was not a
good faith debate i was not
you know piers i don't think it's right
for a news man to say this sort of thing
about the
princess or the ex-princess and i think
this was very
personal it was not in any way intended
to persuade
or to and this guy i don't think was
willing to be persuaded he was saying
yeah she cut you off
loser yeah she yeah you're she's cooler
than you you're not cool
yeah and so you and you're a jerk about
it too and he just says oh oh this is
what we're doing okay well i have no
no reason to engage in that i think
conservatives ought to do that a little
bit more
the left does it to great political
effect but what do we do we
conservatives we just always we go back
on the left-wing news shows
we have the left-wing news out let's
moderate our debates we just got the
news yesterday
from the rnc debate commission that
they're not going to have left wing out
let's moderate
the republican presidential debate good
finally we're
understanding this we're understanding
that
a free marketplace of ideas in that sort
of marketplace people have to set the
rules of the marketplace
and if we're going to engage in commerce
we can't engage in fraud we want to
engage in good
faith commerce here both in you know in
the economic marketplace and also
in the marketplace of ideas
speaking of bad faith deliberation
and discourse don't say i didn't tell
you so
you know how much i hate to say i told
you so on this show
during the election during the 2020
election and then especially right
before the runoff in georgia
joe manchim one of the two
semi-moderate democratic members of the
u.s senate
joe manson from virginia comes out and
he says hey
i am not going to let them get rid of
the filibuster
i'm not going to let the democrats get
rid of the filibuster which
is the only protection we have against
their extremely radical agenda
to not only upend the country but also
maybe give themselves
basically permanent political power at
the national level
i'm not going to let them do take it to
the bank i joe manchin i'm not going to
let them do it
so i asked senator cruz about this on
our show verdict i said what's your read
on joe manchin i said oh yeah joe
manchin you know he's definitely the
most most moderate or one of the most
moderate democrats
but he's never cast a decisive
vote when it really matters
when manchin's going to decide he goes
with his party he doesn't go with his
conservative
constituents he goes with the radical
democratic party
so after months of hearing joan manchin
good old joe manchin's going to save the
filibuster
prevent this deluge joe manchin starts
to crack
on the filibuster i'd make it harder to
get rid of the filibuster
i'm supporting the filibuster i'm going
to continue to support the filibuster
i think it defines who we are as a
senate i'll make it harder to get rid of
it
but it should be painful if you want to
use it you just you should make it
make sure the place works to where okay
i want to work with you
there we go there it is oh i wanna i
love the philip oh man a filibuster and
me we go way back
yeah oh man i would love her i would
never cheat on my filibuster no way i
totally
but but
we shouldn't use the filibuster that
much we should make it hard to use the
philip we should reform we should change
we should this freaking jerk
and he's already he's getting more
questions about this he's saying well
you know my
my views are changing a little well you
know
can't count on him guys can't count on
him
the filibuster is is really great
because
it restrains the passions
of the senate which is supposed to be a
more deliberative body than the house of
representatives
this virtue of restraint seems to be a
common
common thread here whether we're talking
about uh
the southern border whether we're
talking about milo yiannopoulos
or whether we're talking about the
filibuster in the senate
restraint is a good thing conservatives
understand this conservatives
recognize we're not supposed to indulge
all of our
intense passions especially in politics
because then we would be revolutionaries
and radicals we burn the whole place
down we don't want to do that
we realize that you need some restraint
well what the biden administration would
appear to be doing
is taking away all of the restraints
taking away restraints at the border
taking away restraints
in our elections taking away restraints
in our
law making taking away restraints and
restraints
and restraints that
is not going to look great in 2024 or
2022 for that matter
because now they're trying to pass
through this bill hr1
which is going to upend the election
system give congress a huge amount of
authority over congressional elections
gosh what could go wrong there
and take away a lot of election
integrity measures so
what are we even looking at what's our
chance that we can win in 2022 or 2024.
it's looking worse and worse by the day
now before we go i've been told that it
is women's history month
i have not covered this on my show this
is a great oversight
michelle obama is slated to be inducted
into the national women's hall of fame
later this year michelle obama
according to the national women's hall
of fame michelle obama has emerged as
one of the most
influential and iconic women of the 21st
century
and therefore she's going to be inducted
into the women's hall of fame
uh what what has she influenced
would be my first question what has she
done i'm not i'm not even attacking
michelle obama she's the first lady
nobody voted for her nobody would have
voted for her
what did she what was her influence what
is
iconic that's a word i basically would
strike from the english language if
possible it's so overused
unless you're referring to icons i don't
know that one should use iconic
influential in a way she has had
influence do you remember when her
husband was running the first time
and uh then and he wins and she said
that
when the american people elected her
husband
that that was the only time in her adult
life
that she was proud of her country
that well i guess that does exert some
influence because
disdain for one's country for for this
country
has expanded quite a lot
is she responsible for that i don't know
the the notion
that we need to have a national women's
hall of fame
is uh really rich one because it
suggests that they can't compete in like
the national hall of fame you know they
can't compete with the men
but then also because at this very
moment we're being told that
they have to compete with men we're
being told that women in
in high school track have to compete
with men
we're being told that there's no
difference between men and women and a
man who puts on a dress
is therefore a woman and entitled to
beat a girl at track and win her
scholarships and take her spot in
college
that is incoherent the left doesn't
really matter
or doesn't really mind this because for
the left it's the imposition
of their rule is all that matters the
coherence of the rules
doesn't really matter you see this uh
understood in george orwell's 1984 you
see this going on right now
this is another question of restraint
you need to have restrained
or things don't make sense it's the it's
the constraints that
give coherence to the whole body the
borders of the country give coherence to
the country
if you don't have borders you don't have
a country the constraints of biological
sex
are what give coherence to men and women
if men and women are identical if
there's no difference between them then
there's no such thing as women
get rid of the national women's hall of
fame they don't exist because we're all
just one
kind of blob so much for the restraint
was that optimistic
i think i think that is optimistic
because of how much further
down the slippery slope we have to fall
that's our show i'm michael moses the
michael knoll show see you tomorrow
[Music]
producers mathis glover and robert
sterling production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show piers morgan loses his
job for ripping meghan markle
the media rushed to defend awful new
york times pseudo reporter taylor lorenz
and disney's ceo says the gina carano
firing wasn't political the woke
are in control that's today on the ben
shapiro show give it a listen